the programmer humor there a little
program or joke there for you guys
virtual penis network is just it's just
tender that's all it is pretty much I
wonder how like instant it is for women
the dick pics
is it just like is it message three
mm-hmm this is like yo w I'd be dick I
wonder how fast a woman could like if
she was actively trying to have sex
tonight yeah how how quickly that would
happen like how quickly she could lock
it down
or or actually how how how short the TTS
could be time to sex so she decides okay
I want to have sex today
how quickly how quickly can I make this
happen I think get on tinder how quickly
would it take to lock down I see a sesh
I think minutes I mean it's minutes yeah
yeah yeah the time would be dependent on
how fast
Tinder's algorithm could like find a
match yeah yeah like how quickly she can
pull down the new people swipe right
done yeah wanna [ __ ] yep yep done being
the dude on the other end of that but
what yo fellas I gotta go nope just in
the middle of a surgery bull's-eyes mask
yo yo is a can someone cover me I got a
dip you can't weave right now you can't
leave now
it's like a middle of a you know triple
bypass
no like look at this girl dude oh damn
she's fine
it was just like yo just cut that one
[ __ ] in the other [ __ ] Emilia knows what
what to do after that part you got it
alright I'm not I gotta go I gotta go
yo peace yeah yeah
and I weren't yeah I'm across this [ __ ]
tied up going get laid yo [ __ ] her
mouth fam alright alright [ __ ] boy
surgeon yeah you know like like like no
like your heart's all like [ __ ] up and
[ __ ] probably cuz like you ain't been
with me yet so like I'm a fish that [ __ ]
and then like i'ma fix you you know I
mean oh that's so good so it's so good
yo you got a problem with your heart
probably cuz you ain't been with me yet
and like also high cholesterol and it
your your heart's failing so I'm gonna
have to prescribe prescribe yeah I'm
gonna have to prescribe you two things a
little bit of vitamin B egg whites and a
date with your boy I'm have to give me I
want to prescribe you with a little bit
of vitamin D and blood thinners cuz like
it's like really bad for you right now
yeah here's how the [ __ ] here's how
the operation is gonna go right this is
the [ __ ] deal all right I'm gonna go
down on you oh wait now I'm gonna put
you under and [ __ ] my bad
Freudian slip right anyway
that's a smart way of saying like I want
to eat your [ __ ] so just to make things
totally clear so like yeah I'm gonna put
you down under yeah i'ma split you open
[Laughter]
so listen I'm on I'm gonna take my tool
right there I'm gonna split you in half
straight up
I'll go right down the center on that
that beautiful a spot
[Music]
I'll start digging around y'all good
yeah man I'll be just deep in there I'll
just be like oh just like to hand in
that [ __ ] like just deep inside
scrambling yo [ __ ] yes sir can you just
talk about delivering my child can you
just focus gonna be up in them guts
y'all know feel good see I'm saying mix
that [ __ ] around and yeah man brought
did you hear oh now did you hear do you
remember it that's it from love Island
when dr. Alex is talking about
delivering a baby
no he just like it's casually like well
uh you'll cut in it right and then my
outcomes the stomach and like he's like
just then he's like talking about like
having to reach in a woman to like
cradle the baby out like you're he's
like and then like Jack it's like
someone else are like like you reach
inside he's like oh yeah no your hands
are fully in there like like for a
c-section
yeah like grabbing the baby like and
just that image of like you being like
four arms or like wrist deep in a
stomach pulling out a [ __ ] child I
was like yo and then jack is like like
wig to the [ __ ] out he's like it's LA
it's crazy like that's his job good and
shake it like just putting your hand
inside so I so pens yeah
I just sell pens by Dolph I could do
that my yeah yeah
being a doctor or some huh be a doctor
is something don't Umbra that's that's
it
yeah that's the conclusion from all that
damn doctors are sick doctors are a wild
yo doctors be wildin did
[Music]
is that Dustin phone these are custom
pump these are Dustin home
[Music]